hmm at midnight slash grace helbig's on
twitter hi guys I went on my what okay
it is tipsy Thursday here on its grace
where I teach you I have this start of a
sneeze
ah so that's how I sneeze gypsy Thursday
is where I teach you guys how to do
something and I went on my tumblr to ask
you what you wanted to learn how to do
today and someone said don't you wear a
scarf in spring and hey it is springtime
right now and scarves are a great
accessory for ladies and men so I
thought that I would teach you a few
ways that I wear scarves so cue the
voiceover let's get into this you can't
unsee this
you're gonna
I just started feeling really sad all of
a sudden let's do it this first look is
a classic just wrap the scarf around
your neck and keep tucking and wrapping
until it looks like you guessed it a
neck brace not only will you look super
cute but people might feel bad for you
try moving your body side to side
without moving your neck that adds to
the cute effect this next look is called
the sexy ghost guess why and can easily
be turn into the horny ghost guess why
this next look is called the magician
and shilling it's one trick and it's not
that good this next look is called the
pirate whose parrot died before they
were emotionally ready to deal with it
so they use a scarf to replace the thing
that was taken away from them far too
early this next trick requires you to
put the scarf underneath your armpits
and I call it the very medium Acrobat
the next look requires some maneuvering
but it's called the outside underwear
excuse me my eyes are down here next all
you street tuff's out there this one's
called the elegant heroin user
DoubleTap if you agree oh god sorry next
we have one of my favorites called I
didn't get my roots done Thank You
distracted maybe I didn't get my roots I
can easily turn into the Star Trek
google it reading then one of my other
favorites is called my kite doesn't work
and last but not least we have I'm being
kidnapped but it's okay cuz they use a
scar from the gap well there you go
there are some super cute styles that
you can do with the scarf for spring
don't be afraid to experiment unless you
know it's going to be bad then don't
not everyone's a scientist I don't know
I sincerely don't I don't think you guys
have gotten that yet let's see if that
does that again hmm are you going to be
awful card in the camera and just
automatically shut off sometimes and
remind me that I don't have the
technical wherewithal to you figure you
out or are you gonna keep going and
prove to everyone that I may be a crazy
person I swear to god this card was
shutting off a lot before uh-huh is it
gonna [ __ ] no it's going okay I'm happy
about this but I'm also bummed that I
didn't get to prove my point card you
win this time cuz you look so good he
looks so sophisticated and like you own
your own startup business with a really
cute designed website